is here they want they want white
supremacy by ventriloquist effect there
is a black mouth moving but a white idea
through the running on the runway of the
tongue of a figure who justifies and
legitimates of the white supremacist
practices so to have a black face uh
speaking in behalf of a white
supremacist Legacy is nothing new and it
is to the Chagrin of those of us who
study race that the white folk on the
other side and the right Wingers on the
other side don't understand this is
politics 101 and this is race not even
one-on-one what's beneath one-on-one
that was abject pure racism not Reverse
Racism not special racism it was just
old-fashioned racism his line there a
black mouth moving but white idea
running on the runway like how
disgusting is that ideas don't have
color